equality and inclusion lie at the heart
of pride
and while everyone is invited to the
party this year some were more welcome
than others
while a small number of the metropolitan
police were on hand to provide security
serving officers were asked not to march
in uniform as activists hit out about
homophobia in the force including
failings and how it handled the
investigation into the serial killer
stephen port there's a lot of
institutionalized issues that we have to
address
and you know organizations like
metropolitan police really can go out
and do their community engagement
after two-year hiatus because of the
pandemic you can tell from these crowds
just how excited people are for the
return of pride and while it is a
celebration of the milestones that have
been achieved in the last 50 years it's
also a reminder that it isn't all
rainbow flags and glitter
[Music]
amongst the thousands of supporters
a reminder that religious bigotry still
exists but the prime minister giving the
march his approval writing how it gives
him the greatest pride to lead a country
where you can love whomever you choose
to love
he is proposing a ban on conversion
therapy that will not protect trans
people he won't reform the gender
recognition act he is still supporting
that attention
in prison-like conditions of lgbt plus
refugees who are fleeing persecution
abroad until he makes those changes
those are hollow words
asked to lead the parade veteran
campaigners who marched these streets
fifty years ago four or five hundred
people with just as many police looking
very povos
on either side um very disgruntled that
they were having to march with these
people who were
deviants
in my own choir
the guy who was organizing our pride
mart was attacked by homophobes last
night and ended up in hospital with his
boyfriend
that shows if anything shows at all that
what we're doing today is absolutely
relevant
a snapshot of a movement and a
conversation that has completely evolved
over the last 50 years but casting a
shadow over this explosion of color that
in 2022 the lgbt plus community is still
facing discrimination
[Applause]
casey spencer sky news